all right what's up everybody it's
myself random jordan on the couches
today
jake's still on vacation no music no
music
sorry screw all you guys wanted music i
mean i could play like random notes on
the guitar but
you know what we don't even have the
guitars on our hands you have the
harmonic area
so yeah oh yeah we just figured out that
i'm in like this weird acoustic spot in
this room where
there's like a slightly out of sync echo
from me right here have you ever found
that thing like where you're sitting in
a spot like if you make a loud noise and
like buzzes
i i've not you've never noticed that i
mean i don't go around clapping
like maybe you're like sitting somewhere
and like you know you laugh or like you
snap your fingers like you drop
i don't know like you something possible
just picturing every time nico laughs
he's just like
i laugh by snapping my fingers it's
polite but you never noticed like when
something like buzz is weird and echoes
no i have i have yeah it's uh i have
noticed it
acoustic shaping is interesting that's
why we have a lot of
i guess sound absorption material in
here to kind of try to reduce that we
got like what do you call those things
in the corners like
base boomers bass drops bass absorbers
like that yeah base numbers jordan you
never noticed that when you're sitting
like in a stairwell or like
not like the buzzing but i've i've
definitely heard like my echo and i'm
like oh like
hello i've definitely talked to myself
for a little bit
if i'm alone and i hear my echo but i
haven't heard like the is it like z
it's like because it's like the echo is
playing and then dying out really fast
we can just hear the like the sound
slightly offset from itself
so is that a form of resonance yeah it's
an echo it's just uh it's in the spot
where like it's deflecting
right back to yeah but uh an uh
resonance would be an echo that's like
perfectly in sync to
like make the amplitude greater oh right
yeah i don't know
probably not because it wouldn't be
you're not like doing a note that's on
the same frequency the whole time
it's like reverb when you're making a
song
i don't think so i believe reverb and
echo are technically the same thing it's
like i mean harmonics for instance
are would be uh harmonizing
so anyways anyways
tripping himself out i don't know i'm
always reminded of
probably my favorite story of nikola
tesla from
you know back when he was alive there's
a story where he managed to figure out
the natural frequency of the building
because every single object has some
sort of frequency that's inherent to
that object
and it is dictated by things like its
stiffness and its density
stuff like that and he managed to figure
out i guess
it's a story maybe in urban legend that
he figured out
the natural frequency of the building
and he ma and he built like a small
little thing
that vibrated at that frequency and he
attached it to the side of the building
and almost shook the building down
everyone said i was like oh it's an
earthquake and no one else is feeling it
that's how the story goes i mean maybe
it's a little bit of an urban legend but
i could see something kind of happening
because that same thing
similar thing happened with the tacoma
narrows bridge oh gosh
was it that i forget the way it's
commonly yes the tacoma narrows bridge
definitely crashed due to something but
i can't remember the specifics of it
i i actually looked into it or
researched it a little while ago okay
because i
was it wasn't a harmonics thing well let
me take it a step back actually so
in in school i did this class called
physics in the arts which i thought was
just kind of like a
it was a way for like art majors to get
their like one physics credit
that they needed to get to graduate yeah
it's like whatever i'll just take this
class it ended up being a really cool
class that actually went into like all
these things are now useful for like
like when i'm doing 3d rendering or like
sound mixing
like all these other things camera work
like it's like real physics it's in the
arts uh
and one of the things that we actually
talked about or studied was uh like the
harmonic resonance
and the thing like so if you have like
say like a like a
like a tuning fork or like a pendulum
swinging back and forth like
a kid on a swing if you are pushing at
the exact same time they're kind of
reaching that apex of their swing
you don't have to put a lot of effort
into each push to get them
going a little bit further that's
because you're pushing them right when
they're
you know coming to a rest and getting
ready for that next push and then your
push adds on to their
you know kinetic energy their potential
kinetic energy so
it's the same thing like with like
building you know if the top of the
building rocks back and forth like
every second as long as right on that
moment when starting to pick up momentum
in the right direction you push just a
little bit more
you only have to add a little bit at a
time every time it goes back and forth
and eventually it adds up and up and up
until it's swinging really hard
and so the tacoma narrows bridge was
built in a way
whereas like it was a bridge it was a
suspension bridge across a river valley
and the wind would
rush down this valley and kind of like a
reed
uh in a wind instrument the bridge would
start to vibrate everything like you put
a like a piece of grass between your
thumbs and you blow it and it was like
yeah yeah so large scale that started
happening with the bridge
and one day the wind was blowing at a
certain speed where that the uh bridge
was wobbling
and it hit that resonance where the
bridge the wind was causing the bridge
to basically hit that harmonic where it
would kept just adding more and more
energy to itself
until the bridge literally shook itself
apart and it's really crazy there's a
video of somebody
running down the bridge whilst rocking
left and right because the car's parked
and they had to get out of it and i
think no one got killed but but there's
a video of it oh yeah
the video is nuts because you see like
literal concrete just
moving like waves yeah and then the
entire bridge just collapses i've been
over the tacoma narrows bridge
hundreds of times at this point yeah the
new one because they rebuilt it this is
a long time ago
some people died i don't think anyone
died yeah because it was it didn't
immediately fall it was like it starts
rocking and gets bigger and bigger and
bigger because the wind's just
pushing in just that way that the
frequency the video does have the one
dude
like there's one guy who's just walking
across the bridge as it's kind of like
swaying he's like
he's still getting off of it yeah he's
still on it uh
i i assume he got off because i don't
remember there being any deaths also i
i can't when i was in college i also
learned about the tacoma
bridge and i can't remember the
specifics but i think it's
a widely misunderstood cause and i can't
remember if
what you just described is the true
cause or the misunderstood cause of its
collapse
because i remember being like wait i
thought that's how it was and they're
like nope it's actually like this and i
so if anyone in the comments knows how
it actually went down
let us know if niko's right because what
you described makes sense to me
it makes sense to me too that's what i
remember reading like
right yeah no because it was it was
widely misreported
to be the due to something i remember
real engineering made a video about this
a few years back uh brian mcmanus um
and he went into the detail on that so
it makes sense for it to be like that
resonance thing though
you know in terms like so as opposed to
wind just blowing it over and that was
the end of it right yeah
yeah though i know they've changed
bridge design so they don't
uh like catch the wind in a certain way
anymore
yes yes you know that's the one good
thing about
catastrophes is that it's a learning
experience for everyone
that's a positive spin you know how to
not do things in the future that's true
actually that's how scaffolding became
scaffolding yeah it was um a girl was
walking in new york
and a stone fell off an apartment
building and
hit her and she died so they named like
the street after and everything
and so then new york it all started in
new york so they have to do scaffolding
if you're doing any type of
work or you have things that could fall
off
and then you get sued obviously you have
those like basically those walkway
tunnels yeah pedestrian tunnels i
watched a whole like documentary on
scaffolding
was her name
[Laughter]
there's like eva or something
yeah man actually no i think it was
chris i told christian i was like they
should do a stuntman react episode
on just scaffolding because in the
documentary they start
showing all of these fight scenes that
utilize scaffolding because it's
everywhere there's like a lot of jockey
chance yeah i was about to say jackie
chan has done
so much scaffolding work so we were like
what was it rush hour two i think
there's there was like five like i'm
sure i'm sure it was insane
yeah yeah nico you said you had a story
from college
well so in the last podcast we talked
about uh michael jackson the documentary
i brought the idea of oh that's right
you weren't here jordan you were here
yes
you brought the question can you
separate art from the artist and so
uh not to get ahead of myself i'm gonna
rewind this now so
back in in school same college where i
had the physics in the arts class
um we were doing a film i was doing a
film
uh you know major also i double majored
in art and film
and the we're doing a normal lecture and
i think we're looking to talk about
horror films so like we were studying
psycho or something like that
and the the the professor made a joke
about
uh ed gein who's a serial killer and
guy who would rob graves um who lived in
wisconsin
and like you know to me and
pretty much probably 99.9 of the people
there you know he's a character
basically you know he
he's a part of like american folklore of
serial killers uh and then the next day
um the professor started off the class
by apologizing about that which i
thought
my first initial reaction was like
that's weird why are you apologizing and
she probably
the fact that this actually happened
like an hour away from madison wisconsin
or that there might be people in the
class who are actually from the town and
had to live through this and experience
it right
and it was kind of this is a moment that
defined or like that stuck out to me
that kind of defined
the realization that a lot of the time
when you're talking about other people
or other things they're just kind of
background in your world right they're
just they don't feel real
because you don't interact with them but
you know somebody who experienced it or
who's actually gone through it might be
sitting right next to you
and you don't know it and you know
i've tried to take a lesson from it
which is to be aware that you know
these things are real and people do have
to deal with them and
so oddly enough we were talking about
michael jackson
in the last podcast and i'd watch that
hbo documentary which
has left me you know from watching that
it's left me convinced that michael
jackson
you know did what he did watch the whole
thing their accusations me too yes
um and that's you know that's going off
of what i saw in the documentary and
i'm not like a scholar on this thing and
i'm not sure it really even matters to
the world
what my opinion of this is but in the
comments on that podcast
uh taj jackson i don't know if i'm
pronouncing his name correctly but taj
who's related to michael jackson i
believe he's his nephew
uh came in and said like hey you know i
have another perspective on this
if you guys gonna be talking about this
you know i would be interested in having
a conversation with you to give you
a different point of view because
there's a lot of people that are uh
criticizing that hbo documentary and you
know the things that have been said
i mean obviously there's an agenda with
it it was like trying to push
a very specific uh point of view i guess
um which is i think a nature of almost
all documentaries
yeah absolutely absolutely but uh
you know i'd be it was a reminder of
like when when i talk about something
people can be there listening who aren't
to them it's not just another character
in the distance
or another just figure of culture yeah
you know it's
it's something they actually lived
through and went through and
you know that lesson that i tried to
learn in college
you know i forgot about wasn't like
talking about michael jackson the
podcast and sure enough
you know somebody's listening who is
close to that and went through those
you know that moment in time they were
there personally witnessing it you know
and i'd be interested to have a
conversation with taj and kind of hear
you know his story on it i think anytime
you can get a first-person
account of like their experiences with
something it's it's so interesting and
so valuable and so different versus
watching something edited and presented
yeah so
yeah well i wonder how first person his
accounts would be even if he is his
nephew or whatever it's like
how often did he actually see him how
much did he
how well did he get to know him yeah i
think it'd all be interesting things to
find out
because it's like watching that
documentary it's kind of hard
to not believe the doc
yes you know it's like it's pretty well
laid out there's a lot of
experiences that are explained but
and i personally feel like you know as
someone who does video editing
i feel like i have a decent eye for when
a documentary is trying to manipulate me
or make you know construct something
that wasn't quite there like i can kind
of tell when like sound bites are put
together in reality shows from
you know things people didn't say and
they just grab words from here and there
like when
you know they're cutting things certain
ways it's you know for example like in
the tiger king
like every time they cut to carol
baskins like and it's in slow motion
they're playing dramatic music it's like
i'm so clearly being emotionally
manipulated
you know in those shots um i never even
watched that one
i tiger king is
i'm just not into stuff like that
it was very entertaining and fascinating
but i feel like it was also a hit piece
on some people that didn't deserve it
and kind of a heroic piece for other
people who didn't deserve it
you know i it makes me a little bit
worried about how fascinated are
with people who like don't deserve our
fascination
yeah i think that's was like why i don't
really pay attention to stuff like that
i think that's good i think the most we
can do is speak with our own
actions and intentions yeah yeah i think
part of the reason why
tiger king became so like blown up was
that it just dropped at the perfect time
all right absolutely but i i ended up
avoiding it
partly out of just not really being
interested but also because i had heard
some things and i kind of looked into it
a little bit i'm like it's about this
guy who's like
not that good and it kind of builds him
out to be kind of a cool guy like
nah i don't want to everyone was him for
halloween and
yeah and i'm like and if you're from
those parts like you already kind of
know that people live like that to begin
with
like i'm from the south and like redneck
area like none of that was shocking to
me it was just
very all elaborated and
made up this is literally just a story
that they're putting together and it
dropped at the beginning of the pandemic
like i see those type of people growing
up all the time there's nothing new to
this
i wonder about that that aspect of
personal experience too or like
you know to all of us not all of us to
most of us the tiger king
and all that like they're just
characters you know they're not real
but some people had to deal with that
and some people had to go through that
and you know there's a lot of like
horror stories within all that
the same thing with like a lot of the
like serial killer
like true crime things that you know you
see on netflix you know party's like
would what if you were in that family
and like you know
your loved one was killed by the serial
killer and now you see them being made a
movie star
like how does that feel like that's
pretty probably pretty crappy yeah
it probably feels awful yeah people are
listening to like the murder podcasts in
the car and like
just like gently looking like i remember
i was listening to one because i was
bored and that was in the car and
she looked at me and she was like are
you okay
i'm listening to someone's horror story
and i was like and i guess it is kind of
weird
i'm like just excited to be hearing
about how someone was killed
i mean there's definitely an aspect of
like you know
there's only so much experience you can
get on your own so you gather the
experiences of others in your lifetime
to broaden
your horizons and your wisdom and all
that kind of stuff but like
i feel like there's a there's a fine
line between like
you know it being an insight into like
how humans function and how society
works versus like
just taking somebody's trauma and pain
and using it for entertainment
and i think there's a lot of like
there's a lot of amazing documentaries
on
true crime and serial killers and all
that kind of stuff and there's also
amazing shows on it
but there's also i think a lot of
exploitative stuff too and it's
it's definitely mixed into one big mush
recently
yeah did you guys see that one uh
documentary series on netflix
recently like a few months back it was
about uh that one
woman who died at the hotel in downtown
l.a what's the name of that it's like
the cecil
yeah the cecil hotel my roommate watched
it i never watched it
i get scared i don't know i don't watch
i was like into it but
uh jenna ended up finishing it without
me oh no
but i guess you can go to the hotel we
did yeah it's still there in downtown
l.a
uh we rode by were you with us when we
were buying it we did it in the uh
evening one time we were on like some
ride in downtown l.a and uh
wait yeah no christian you were there i
was with you and yeah we rolled right by
the seas hotel and it's like
they'd taken the name down on the front
but it's still painted up on the side up
at the top so you can still see it
yeah didn't i don't i didn't see it but
it wasn't the
i mean i guess the spoiler spoilers if
you care uh
didn't it turn out that she had like
some sort of mental illness
or something then it like costs someone
finished the documentary without me
but i mean the general if you're not
aware basically
uh this woman got lost
no she was missing big difference um she
was missing
and then the internet started basically
trying to find her
a bunch of investigative armchair
experts and
they ended up finding her in the water
tower on top of the hotel so
everyone in the hotel had been drinking
she was in the water tower i thought she
had the fall and like behind it and like
got wedged between
was she in the water tower she was
floating in the water that's awful
the water supply for the whole whole
hotel
and everyone had been drinking and
bathing in
dead body water dead body tea oh yeah
because it's also hot nelly
oh my god
sorry jordan like what do you do do you
get it like you're a refund
one star yeah i have no idea
well that hotel has had a lot of like
there's a lot of crime that happened a
lot of crime yeah they're constantly
getting
police calls there and stuff like that
but like i can't believe that hotel
didn't go under after that
event like no public city is bad
publicity they say i mean
at this point it's now more of a well
done did people know about that body in
the water tower thing
they didn't until the police were all
around and it
the news got out and there are news
i didn't know about it before the
netflix documentary oh really yeah oh i
remember it going
down when i think we're doing sync
really
it was around that time i think cause
how many years
i don't know like eight years ago
something like that it's relatively
recent
yeah yeah relatively recently yeah it
was uh
the hotel's not functioning right no
it's still a hotel you can go live there
or stay there you can go live there
welcome to the season hotel it just
sounds creepy too like
the bates motel sounds better than that
place yeah
the bat is motel betty's
that was cool speaking of netflix series
i rewatched uh beau burnham's inside
again a few nights ago with it
and i still haven't seen it i want to
finish watching it i've only seen the
first like
15 minutes it's a work of art it's it
really captures
a moment in someone's story during the
pandemic and
he is clearly extremely talented and
writes some really
interesting music because it starts off
as kind of like jokey kind of music but
like there's
this undercurrent of him actually like
having messages he's kind of trying to
deliver and then little by little as
like the show goes on
and his time working on this alone goes
on his music starts to just become
personal music
like there's still you know quips and
moments and stuff but like
at certain points he's just singing
songs that are personal songs and
he's bo burnham is clearly you know
watching inside he's very
focused on you know how the internet is
affecting people's perception of
society and reality and their self-worth
and all that kind of stuff
but one thing that stood out to me
watching the second time i didn't really
notice the first time
is you know he there's a lot of
negativity in it
like there's a ton of negativity and
there's jokes and i feel like part of
being a comedian is you take things that
are hard to talk about or things that
are
you know would have negative emotions
and you bring them out so you can
process it but you use comedy
so that you don't feel as much pain when
you're processing it you know
whether it's an uncomfortable thing to
talk about or a thing that makes you
angry you know
it's a way to do that without actually
having to be
angry when you talk about it you know um
and there's parts in the in this movie
where bo burnham's like you know saying
he's like having a really hard time
he's sounding really angry and you know
struggling with depression or at least
that's
you know the impression i get and the
songs really echo that too
um but one thing that i also noticed
is i can't think of it any moment in in
the video
and maybe jordan if you you know think
of it let me know
through so maybe okay but i can't think
of one time he mentions
one thing that he's thankful for you
know or excited for
like specifically thankful like
at no point does he ever say like i'm
thankful i have
this to work on or i'm thinking i have
this space to use
i'm thankful i have the abilities i have
like there's not
one moment of like that pause because
there's a lot of self-reflection in like
talking about his like
inner thoughts but it's it's all
negative
and watching the second time for as much
as i like and how great it is
it definitely sticks out to me a little
bit more and it's almost a little
off-putting for me at least for the
second half
um do you guys can you guys think of any
moment when he
like christian jordan no no not the
parts that i saw now that
it's is like a beautiful cry for help
yeah this is kind of
my first impression i feel like i feel
like it's hard
to be i'm gonna get into some
philosophical stuff here
um it's easy to always be like trying to
fix something or
worry about something what's the next
thing you're gonna deal with what's the
task you have to have at hand what's the
work you have to do
it's always it's easy to focus on the
problems that you have to solve
and i think it's a little harder to
pause and be thankful for the things
that you have achieved or that you
already have but i think
if you're never thankful for something
you're gonna have a hard time being
happy
because i think the nature of being
happy in essence of that
is the nature of appreciating and being
thankful for the things
that are bringing you joy because if
you're not thankful for anything then
how are you even happy
you know if you're not thankful for like
having a good meal or having friends or
you know a nice evening or a good movie
that you just watched like if you're not
thankful for that experience then how
did you enjoy it
yeah you know unless you're just
enjoying it and you're taking it for
granted which
i think we all tend to do once in a
while but that's more of i think just a
oversight
as we kind of breeze through it well i
mean as you said it's like
it's kind of hard though because you're
saying it kind of seems like
you know he's suffering from depression
in which case it's you know
it's extremely difficult to be happy you
know
chemically yeah for sure and so
then you combine that with you know a
complete lack of social
interaction and
yeah i mean i don't know this isn't this
is me trying to say like
oh you should just you know here's how
to be happy it's more of an observation
of
i think you know not saying one causes
the other it's more of a correlation
but if if you aren't if you're not
pausing to think about the things
you're thankful for you may not be
taking the time to pause and think about
the things
that are making you happy um because
it's easy just keep thinking about the
next thing you have to deal with
yeah because like there's always things
to be thankful for but like
you know if you look at me as 18 me now
like i've achieved a lot of things that
me at 18 was hoping to achieve but they
just kind of become a thing that you're
doing along the way
you know it's like okay i have a you
know i have a job i have a place i have
a wife i have a kid wow you know like
these are things i should be thankful
for but then you know
oh i'm thinking about the next day i get
this project done and then i have to go
to the you know
to the doctors here and with this
appointment for milo and i have to go
and do this and it's like
you just think about the next thing you
have to do and you're not pausing to be
like whoa hold up hold up
like don't get frustrated about that big
picture be thankful for the fact that
you just
you have this to begin with because this
is what you've always wanted and i think
it's really easy to just breeze by
you know if you say if it's something
you've always wanted once you have it
it's
it's really really easy just to breeze
by that and start thinking about the
next thing
you never pause to yeah i appreciate it
that perspective is important and it can
be really challenging to
grab hold of it's like a hamster wheel
that everyone is on but we're not really
taught to hop off the hamster wheel yeah
you're supposed to be worried you're
supposed to want to go buy the new thing
or
why is this person doing that i want to
go here i want to go on vacation and
then
you know people are just working to live
at this point no one's really just
living
or being happy but that's like society
you think of advertising and marketing
and
no one is telling you to be happy no one
they're just throwing like
pharmaceutical stuff for you
bad food and it takes a lot like
i think he was saying it does it is much
harder to be happy but if you just
try to like send to yourself or be
around people or
you know just take a moment meditate and
say what you're grateful for that's what
we try to do glass half full rather than
glass half empty and i found myself
complaining a lot less
and yeah you know like how you said i
just a couple years ago i didn't have a
job and i didn't know how money was
gonna come sometimes
now i have a job i don't worry about
money but some days i
forget that now i have money and now
it's just the next thing of well i'm not
doing this
but two years ago i couldn't even think
that far you know
you just have to be very happy with how
you're progressing
yeah it's important because the goals
are always shifting
yeah and that you know if you're always
trying to achieve a goal but you always
have new goals you're never going to
achieve your goals
you know so it's it's good to stop and
be thankful for having something
yeah yeah i kind of the same feeling
where like i was feeling more anxious
about things a few months back like
it was kind of creeping up on me it's
like why is my mindset like this all of
a sudden like what changed
like i don't really have things to be
anxious of you know outside of just
normal life
and running a company well but still
it's like it's not like it's my first
year doing it at this point yeah
i know i know like i'm surrounded by a
bunch of people who are you know
good friends and like also making this
all happen like i have an awesome team
like we're all together here and you
know if one of us
gets sick or something like that and is
out for a month it's like okay and the
rest of the team will adapt you know
um we have really cool shows that i
really enjoy doing like i love doing the
effects i just react like
you know zooming out it's like i sure
there's responsibilities and there's the
occasional stresses and that's fine
and like that's life but like i don't
really have something to be
anxious about in a deep core way
you know and if i'm feeling that i need
to stop and reevaluate
like what am i doing what's my
perspective on things that's causing
this
exactly create our anxiety or someone
told me like when you're worrying about
something you're just
kind of predicting the future that
hasn't even happened yet yeah like
you're kind of ruining what could
possibly happen because you're like
this it's gonna be this way and i'm
gonna be so worried
yeah it could all just be fine it
normally is when you think of the grand
scheme of things
like if you're what are you complaining
about i'm like there's so many more
people going through so much worse
all the time yeah i mean mindset in
perspective like
i think it's a bit taboo to say that you
know you have control over your emotions
and your perspectives on things but
it's true to some extent like you do you
do influence your perspective
and the experiences you have influences
your perspective and
the experiences you have is because of
the actions you take so
you know there are things we can do as
individuals to push ourselves and step
ourselves towards these
places we want to be and i think it's
important to acknowledge as well
that you know we can actively work
towards the things we want to have or
experience or feel
whether or not we can get there without
help you know i'm not saying that's a
guaranteed thing but i think it's
important
welcome to the corridor cast where we're
a philosophy podcast
futurology philosophy podcast
whatever this deep conversation hour
nico wren
jordan is there is there any pm is there
any new tech
any cool like tech stuff i
don't i don't know tell me about your
feelings whatever
oh man you guys teach me the tech stuff
yeah my shoulder had surgery last week
oh right yeah
uh how'd that go
this isn't just like any little little
surgery it was a legit thing i had to
get in there
so i don't specifically know exactly
what they did yet because
the surgeon didn't know what he was
going to do before the surgery
and he wasn't around after the surgery
and the nurse didn't know anything so
i have three holes in my shoulders three
surgeon came in
did something and then disappeared and
they're like we don't know where he went
kinda like paul read i mean he's uh the
surgeon is the same doctor who i've been
seeing for
my shoulder to begin with in the
clavicle and i like him a lot
uh but at the same time it's like i i
have three holes in my shoulder and i
don't know why he said there might be
one or two and i woke up at three
i woke up uh lecturing the nurse
on archimedes and buoyancy
and apparently she's i i vaguely
remember her going oh that's nice yeah
yeah and that was that was like my first
moment of consciousness i didn't like
wake up i just remember being like wait
why are you saying yeah
some of that like yeah she's like oh
yeah you're talking about nurses
deal with some of the like most dumb
stuff
and so i told jenna that she's like yeah
that that makes sense that that that
happens a lot
patients say a bunch of stupid things
apparently can you take us back to that
moment and actually lecture me for men
and archimedes and buoyancy
no do you tell me what you know what i
know i made a whole video about it
a few months ago i mean yes like you
know archimedes he was an old greek
philosopher and
was tasked by the king to figure out
whether or not the king's
crown was pure gold or not and
the how does it how does this
go he like he basically knows the weight
of pure gold like the density of gold
and so he could he also can figure out
the volume
of the crown by submerging it in water
because by submerging something in water
the water level will rise
by by the exact volume of that object
and so then you have the volume of
something and the supposed
density or rather no you have the volume
of something and the density of
something
so therefore you can figure out how much
it should weigh and if it's pure gold it
should weigh
a certain amount if it's been cut with
anything like maybe a little bit of lead
or something
or a little bit of i don't know iron i
don't know what they would have cut it
with copper
copper maybe yeah it would weigh a
little less
and the crown weighed a little less as
legend has it supposedly apparently that
story is not actually
uh feasible at all imagine how mad you'd
be if you're the king
and you're you've been wearing a crown
that is not pure gold
like they had like so little like to
wear like that's what they cared about
back then and he was probably pissed
he's so heavy crown right that's the
thing we got wrong with our battlefield
series
we kind of knew it because it's
impossible to like to portray it right
but gold bars are incredibly heavy a
single golden bar is like 30 pounds
so just like what would be like five
gold bars and you're
approaching my weight that's enough to
like
hold in my hands like this when they're
like stealing gold bars
yeah i'm like throwing them around yes
we had to get people getting duffel bags
they didn't
they did it well in die hard
three remember when they stole the gold
out of the fort knox
it was samuel jackson and he remembers i
remember him saying man this is heavy
this is gold it's a bar gold yeah
i really want to buy one of those uh
tungsten cubes that you can get they're
really expensive i know uh jesse
driftwood got one for like
400 bucks and it's like a one and a half
inch
cube so it's not very big but because
it's pure tungsten which is an
incredibly heavy element
it feels way heavier than it should be
than it appears to be i'm like i really
want
something like that but i don't think
it's worth four hundred dollars what's
that aerosol gel that's like
uh that
it is the lightest element it is also
the most thermally insulating element
because it's basically just air
sorry material you're right is it is
literally
like 99.99 air it's just like a lattice
work of
silica that's super incredibly thin
so it's like foam like but hard like
mega foam yeah plastic foam
imagine like you're to take like foam
like say off the top of beer whatever
and harden it
and then also make it all the uh the
film
way thinner wow and even more bubbles
that and uh playing with some arrow gel
and playing with some like vanta black
paint would be really fun i've been i've
been wanting to do a vantablack
uh video for a while now where we just
get up i mean i guess
we couldn't technically get vanta black
specifically but there's a bunch of
different types of
vantablack either like illegal or well
the
owner of it or the inventor the
copyright holder
the patent i'm not exactly sure but
basically he has made it so that
no one else can purchase it but there's
a lot of copycat
pigments out there that are basically
just as dark they absorb all the light
so
i really want to see something like that
in person where you just paint something
and it just
it looks like a black hole except for
the fact that it's an actual
like object i wonder what kind of heat
it picks up probably a lot
yeah because absorbing 100 of the light
will not hundred but you know 99 of the
light radiation
yeah like if you were to like paint the
wall with it it would just look like
nothing
you would see no contours you would see
like imagine like taking
like a statue of like a cat or something
like you 3d print a cat and
you paint it in vantablack it would just
look like a silhouette
at all times even if you shine a
flashlight at it it would just like the
flashlight would just not appear
that's cool it's pretty nice and i've
been wanting to get some of that so we
can do like a bit of like an
investigative video about it like
actually like taking pictures cranking
up the iso and exposure and like
bringing it into
photoshop or after effects to like
really sample the light values and
really just kind of
figure out what exactly this paint
does to like film sensors and whatnot
like how does it actually optically
interact with everything how expensive
is it
i don't know it sounds expensive i mean
it's it's pricier than regular paint but
i don't think it's like four hundred
dollars a can
imagine if your car expensive you had
your car painted
here's a car painted in it okay yes
i've seen that yes yeah you're saying i
was like
i wonder if they color corrected this at
all
it's not bad it just it makes it makes
the camera
look like they just are really bad at
using a camera
yeah like give me a different angle like
this is a different angle yeah it makes
the car look fuzzy
it does yeah like when people get the
really bad like matte
wraps or something yeah that's what it
reminds me of this actually looks pretty
cool there's another like i remember
looking up a video for another like
vantablack ripoff that's pretty
disappointing with the results maybe
like the guy didn't like make a point of
shooting it to make it look really black
but like
you can see the contours really like it
was just like you painted it with like a
really nice black paint and like that's
all i had
this however like the car is basically
100 black
you said it looks fuzzy and i find that
really interesting because i mean
something like velvet
has a very very low index of refraction
reflection index it it doesn't reflect
well
and so it you know it gives you that
matte sort of look
and it's it might it's gonna appear
fuzzy because that does not reflect
anything you don't see any reflections
like it just this does look like
like you can see the contours yeah it's
dark
don't get me wrong it's a very dark car
it's insane but yeah you're right i can
see
shape to the door it looks like it's all
fuzzy
it's a bunch of black felt yeah that's
an interesting thing about velvet that's
why they use velvet for like the black
velvet for like uh
like magic backdrops like when they're
doing like invisible man productions
okay sure it's the same thing it absorbs
all that light
has anyone went to the madcap motel yeah
mad cat hotel
i don't know it's so everyone
knew about it from tick tock it was an
ad or it was someone who had already
went and
it's just this girl going through all of
these different rooms and experiences
reminding me a lot of when niko was
talking about omega mart
so you go through and you go through
with the crowd and they're taking you
through a journey through this motel and
it's like all theatrical and one room is
like
pitch black and there's like lights
going down or there's mirrors everywhere
and you're just like exploring with
different lights and you can play
games but looking through tunnels
there's a room that's all
sideways so everything in the room is
just sideways
but it's okay and then everyone in line
is like how did you hear about it and
we're like tick-tock
but you guys have never heard of it it's
literally right downtown it's called
madcap motel
sounds really nice so they have hotels
and gaming controllers
[Laughter]
[Music]
now christian's laughing that went right
over my head
madcatz is a company that makes like
off-brand kind of
middle to low-tier quality gaming
controllers for
gaming consoles uh
yeah so my surgery went well i they tore
the
sorry i tore the labrum and broke the
socket bone a little bit i know i've
talked about this before i apologize uh
the surgeon told me there's nothing they
can do about the bone
i was like oh okay that was not what you
told me last time we talked about okay
there's supposedly a bone chip in there
you're gonna take that out right like
i don't know i don't know i'll find out
on friday if we call you chip for the
rest of the time that you're here
so then the the two days after that
were probably the most rough not because
of the pain but because
of the lack of pain specifically the
lack of any feeling because i had a
nerve block done
and the nerve block was pretty intense
because it paralyzed the entirety of my
arm
from like pretty much my collarbone all
the way down to my fingertips and i
couldn't feel or move them at
all like it's so bizarre to look at your
hand
and try to like all right move your
finger and you're like you're activating
the muscle in your mind
and then just nothing happens it's like
ghost something because
like amputees deal with it when they
lose their legs yeah i think that's
i think that's a little different
because the phantom limbs that's where
they actually feel
pain where they shouldn't my favorite
my favorite bad guy from the adventure
brothers phantom limb
phantom limb he's just a guy legs
they're invisible
yeah and so and that like wasn't that
big of a deal like it's like touching my
skin my skin felt really rough because
it was just like
someone else's skin that wasn't that big
of a deal except the
overall feeling was that like it felt
like i was
my arm was pinched in in
going to sleep you know how like when
you sleep on your arm wrong or you've
been like leaning on your arm a little
while and you start feeling it go to
sleep it felt like that
that moment right there when it's
starting to go to sleep and it's
uncomfortable
like that makes sense yeah it's the same
thing kind of isn't it your nerve not
responding to that
yeah no it is but you know you would
think that
because you can't feel anything it's
fine but it felt distinctly like oh i'm
pinching my arm
i really need to move it so that i can
get blood flow back it's a very
overwhelming sensation
for my brain to be like trying to move
your arms so that like
you can get that feeling back and you
can't and you can't yeah yeah
and so then after a couple days that
nerve block started going away
and uh my feelings started coming back
and it wasn't that big of a deal as far
as like the pain in my shoulder i had
some pain
meds that were helping with that but
overall
i think my shoulder surgery and the
recovery from it has been far
smoother and easier than the collarbone
i feel like i was planning for this and
i was like you know what
no it's like okay this is how it is i'm
learning snowboarding
and i got a snowboard i'm all excited
about it i get up to the ski hill
i'm going up the bunny slope and i'm
like hmm all right before i do the bunny
slope
i'm going to go down this double black
diamond is a real story or an analogy
[Laughter]
you shouldn't be doing any of that right
now i just have a really awful time
going down the black diamond
rest a little bit i'm like okay now i'm
going to go down the bunny slope
and i do it i'm like okay that wasn't
that bad but it's only not that bad
because i did the double black diamond
the double black diamonds are
collarbones snapping exactly yeah
yeah what is a nerve block is it like uh
like anesthesia onto the nerve
i'm not exactly sure so i want i did
that like closes
she opens up who goes there
feeling
i i i'm not exactly sure i i mean when
it comes to nerve stuff i have no idea i
don't know if they did some sort of
like acupuncture type deal where they
actually like injected something into
the nerve ending in my arm like there's
probably some main
nerve that goes from like through my
shoulder and hits
everything in my arm and they probably
just tapped it up there but i don't know
if that was something they put in my iv
or something they applied directly to
the shoulder that they have to
specifically
hit the nerve with it uh it wasn't my
general anesthesia that was a separate
thing so
so they do this on purpose yes okay yes
specifically so that i wouldn't
feel the pain as intensely because
yeah i can imagine though could that be
dangerous like if you tap it too hard
and you're just like oh
sorry yeah never again will you feel i
mean that's a dangerous uh
uh what's the and what's it called when
when someone's
going into labor and they give them
anesthesia
on the bottom half of their body
basically so they don't have to feel
it's much like the
epidural that's done wrong it'll
paralyze you
yeah because they're putting it right
into your spinal column other people are
like i'm doing a natural birth and it's
like until they're doing the natural
birth and they're like
nope come come i'll take a little
epidural yeah yeah they have to turn you
over and they put it right into your
yeah but it has it has that risk and
they make you sign you know papers for
it being like look if you mess it up
you might not walk again man modern
medicine
and medical knowledge is just truly
something
a wonder to behold it is like incredible
what they did to my shoulder had it been
like 15 years ago they would have just
like made this huge scar
up through my my whole arm here to pull
back all the skin and then just directly
operate on
the flesh the labrum and all that stuff
inside
but no they made three different
incisions that are like
barely half an inch long and then they
send in little robot arms
like little like articulating like
a little like the sentinels in the
matrix pretty much actually yeah
and so one hole was for the camera the
laparoscopic camera that goes in
underneath the skin to the zone and the
the closer
one is for the actual little arm that
has more arms on
it little like grippers little knives uh
just to
you know and one with like i think they
sutured up the labrum so there had to be
like a little sewing needle
well i don't know machine just going
like snow white or something i mean yeah
maybe i think i got the same thing done
for my
appendix oh and i sure had appendicitis
and then i woke up and i had
three tiny little yeah incisions and
then they gave me the stitches that
dissolve right
are they gonna dissolve inside no i have
to get them taken out um oh really
yeah cause i gotta stick another little
sticking to ya
no i mean and jenna mighty actually take
these out herself
oh you mean oh wait you don't have any
sutures inside your body
you must i think i do i think they're
that teflon nylon
combo and i think it's just there
forever oh cool maybe it'll dissolve
into i don't know honestly i don't know
yeah the exterior stitches well i mean
okay because as long as it's been there
long enough like
you can literally just cut the sutures
yourself like you literally don't have
to go to the doctor to
cut cut outs when you cut it do you have
to pull the strings out yes
i don't do well with that type of stuff
in movies
can you put like a get a microphone like
a really sensitive microphone and put it
next to it when you pull the string
through god yeah that'd be awesome
a few months ago jenna cut her finger
really badly cutting onions and so we
went
to the hospital she got stitches i think
she had like five stitches in her finger
and you know i think you have to keep
the stitches in for like two weeks or
something like that and then like we
were just watching a movie one night and
she's like i'm going to take my stitches
out
i'm like trying to enjoy this movie
she's like snip snip
it's like no big deal that's so awful
i mean she takes out stitches all the
time so she's like a pro at it but it's
like
the worst part of movie training drink
one and watch a movie someone saved
someone and they're like just happen to
be a medic and they have this like
makeshift needle and thread and they're
like i'll i'll stitch you up and then
they're like throw alcohol on it and
just
change and i'm like i don't i just think
i would keep the wound
open i don't know i can just watch a
needle just
put together let's do tape and uh i'll
get to the doctors yeah
yeah one of the things you got to be
careful of is to not pierce too far
below the skin and not hook any of the
muscle
oh my goodness i don't can you just sew
your skin
to your muscle and it's like that's not
enough because then the moment you flex
it it rips through
[Laughter]
yeah but i'm sick
literally all right cool
see what time is it more time to talk so
how do we recover from that's a nice
shirt you wearing there niko thanks
what i'm wearing here yeah me a couple
of blue button-up boys over here
blue jeans and vessies yes we are
wearing like
literally the same same clothes
and then i'm like this podcast not
sponsored by bessie
but the shoes are comfy i must say wow
yeah so we did a bob ross video today
yep
and i guess after this podcast the
instagram posts will go up because
did you put yours in the render folder i
have not yet okay um
but it's like ready to go i alright like
i already have it on my phone and
everything but
it's uh not in the folder where it needs
to be
so that'll be the first thing i do after
this but yeah i guess you guys will post
that tonight or tomorrow
tonight it'll all be anonymous yeah
and uh everyone votes on who
i guess had the best render wait so what
is the bob ross challenge red right now
he wasn't there i should probably add
some context to that as opposed to
explaining the ending
um bob ross is a famous painter most of
you guys we know who bob ross is
he was born did you know he is more
famous than andy warhol
you know yeah probably because
millennials yeah that makes sense
yeah he's uh he became an internet
sincerely yeah yeah so
we decided to try to do a render
challenge sorry
i didn't even hear you said andy
warhol's overrated is what i said oh
yeah
i'm sure don't don't get jan talking
about andy warhol he will
he will talk your ear off about how
overrated he is
uh yeah so bob ross we decided to
basically try to follow one of his
painting tutorials but do it in cg
and did a whole render challenge about
it so we all tried to recreate one of
his paintings
in 3d there's a special note an asterisk
next to this that i think there's a few
asterisks which one are you talking
about
the biggest one which is we did it in
real time watching the episode oh
yeah did anyone ring the bell we all
rang the bell
okay i was kind of part of me was hoping
like someone like sam
would uh maybe like refuse to ring the
bell like maybe he was doing all right
and
we're like sam come on ring the bell we
need you to do it he's like
no oh he never rung but he really built
it here we all there we also needed as
much time as possible so are we posting
the original yeah as well
the renders so the renders well the bell
just explains you guys so the episodes
are 27 minutes long bob ross makes this
entire picture
in real time 27 minutes
so we did like we looked at the final
result for five seconds yesterday just
five seconds we couldn't look at it
again
we were able to gather assets so we're
not like modeling trees
and mountains like you're able to grab
your tree models
grab whatever you like you're just
grabbing models you're not building the
shot you're just grabbing what you need
um so you're able to gather assets and
then in real time in these
in this 27 minute episode we have to
build our render at the exact same time
that he's making the painting
and we all have a bell that we can ring
once and it buys us five minutes
yeah that's we pause it on pause for
five minutes so like
why did you ring your bell what happened
when you had to ring yours i don't know
i think i was starting to feel a little
bit of panic and i was like
so he was panicking what part of the
painting were you on oh i
don't i think i was still trying to make
like the ground and he was already
moving on to like the foreground trees i
was like oh i'm so behind
oh he loves those foreground trees oh
he's foreground trees he's
the best the rocks that he does like he
was making
a forest faster than i could like import
a tree model
yeah i couldn't copy paste faster than
he could make treats
i already had a nice tree in there i'm
like he's like another one and another
one another one like whoa
i can't even like click and drag this
fast we also
had no undo yeah no control
z doesn't control c daniels i saw daniel
doing that before i was like what are
you doing and then he just starts
sprinting away i was like why do i even
ask
which i should probably get off the
computer at some point
i mean i was able to use ctrl z in after
effects after we're done
so i don't know if it was like a
computer computer-wide macro that he
made or specifically for
oh it was just on the laptop
[Music]
interesting yeah so that was the other
thing we did we were using very powerful
desktop workstations
yeah but we're all sitting around on
laptops which is actually hard
is the coolest thing that worked really
well honestly
i got like one like hey your nets may be
a little slow but i didn't notice a
single issue
i got none of that yeah yeah it works
really well i know sam
said he was having some issues sarah's
gpu crashed on his
workstation so he had to he had to ring
the bell right upstairs
restart his computer run back downstairs
and keep going and that was his bell
time
yeah that was his belt time yeah
the uh the renders will be on the
quarter digital instagram by the time
you're hearing this
they've already gone up um so just a
good reason if you're not following us
on instagram to follow us on instagram
because then you'll get to see those
things when they actually go live
and i guess we'll do a poll or something
like that yeah some i don't know how
what the best way to do that is maybe
any predictions for what the winner is
going to be
i think it might be you i don't know we
can't describe our stuff at all
no no but people are going to see it
this is
this is probably wait what days this is
going up on friday still though
it's like oh yeah people wouldn't have
seen the video won't be done the video
won't be out
true but they'll have seen the renders
and they'll know the winner
yeah but they won't know they just they
just know
no i think i think we can let's you can
tell me your opinions on the pictures
because people can already see the
pictures
they don't know that we don't like we
don't know who the winner is yet and
they won't either
i mean they're all they're all they're
all renders all right jordan
your friend doesn't want to commit i
don't i don't
i like the idea of anonymity here so
that there's no
bias going in and it's just pure
artistic judgment
on what was made yeah but
i didn't even see the podcast is
happening after the instagram was posted
people seen it
but before the final video goes out
right but you're
right we can still talk about it i don't
know
okay whatever whatever i thought they
were all pretty cool uh
i mean yeah they're how was matt how was
matthews how did matthew do
matt did well i think he was a little uh
i don't think he's used to
doing stuff like this his was great yeah
he was pretty good
uh he had a couple of like weird texture
issues from like he had a lot of
technical problems
so also matt is not the mat that you
guys know
there's a new mat in town i thought
first you thought you were talking about
me i was like
yes we have a new mat in town so as you
guys know we did the cgi generalist
uh applications a while back a bunch of
people applied a bunch of amazing
artists
hundreds like literally like 400 people
over 400 people applied
so matt is one of the uh i guess you
could say one of the finalists
it makes it sound like a contest it's
not a contest um it's just
a job application yeah it kind of got
narrowed down to like a top six or
whatever i think
and so there's you know in this process
you end up meeting a lot of really
interesting artists so matt is one of
them and uh he's from philadelphia so we
invited him out to la for a week to
spend some time in the studio get to
know him is it just this week it's not
like two weeks just this week
he goes back saturday or sunday oh wow
all right
yeah and then yeah someone else is
coming in next week oh do i need to i'm
probably gonna book his hotel
okay that's great no i live in l.a oh
yeah oh okay
[Laughter]
so let's not tell him that he could have
had a hotel
yeah well i mean yeah there's a few
people i mean
it's it's always awkward for me to kind
of like consider
this stuff because it's like because of
our reach there's a lot of
very very talented people who would like
to work with us and we the problem is
that we can't work with
everyone and there's a lot of things
that we have to kind of keep in mind
when it comes to trying to
think of a new hire it's not just what
work
can they do it's like how well can they
work with the team
especially in this type of environment
where you're very likely going to be on
not just on camera but you need to be
like good on camera
and and yeah so
i mean there's a lot of things and so i
guess this this isn't exactly like a
final
interview with i guess it kind of is
it's more just like i mean
well you guys want to just come hang out
with us for a week see what happens yeah
well part of our hiring philosophy too
when it comes to hiring people here is
that like
we're not like mcdonald's where it's
like look i need something to do this
job
specifically like i need a human
processor a robot i give you input you
give me output like
there's times we know that there's times
when that happens
but that's not how we work here it's
it's more we need
people who have artistic abilities
or talent or a craft or a skill and then
what they're able to do will
shape what we make with them because
we're not we're not making a set product
it's not like you know
i have i have an order for a thousand of
these widgets and you need to make a
thousand and
exactly the same it's you know the
people around us influence what we do
it's what kind of video we're gonna make
this week what what kind of project can
we do together if we if we
if we make a a corridor short film like
what kind of cool effects
do you know how to do and then this
comes together together
this comes together to influence and
create the final product so
you know in terms of hiring people it's
more about bringing people in
experiencing
kind of who they are and what they bring
to the table and then
looking at what would that look like if
you added that ingredient to the
corridor stew
how would the broth come out yeah it's
like can you be flexible with your
creativity
like can you you know you come in as one
person and then
you start kind of getting tested with
all these different like that like he
wasn't expecting to do with
bob ross spending like under time and
then you start
figuring out other skills you have and
what you can add to the table
you yeah learn something new about
yourself all the time here i feel like
and not other places that you get hired
at maybe more corporate places
you're not supposed to like they hired
you for one thing and like you stay in
your cubicle and you
you do that over and over and over and
over again that sounds like the worst
it does well that's why people you know
they watch these videos and they do want
to work here so bad because i think they
do get a sense of that because we're
always
evolving and trying new things actually
i take it back some days
some days i wouldn't mind just having a
list of things to do and i just do that
one thing that's what jake does
well jake makes his list but some days i
wouldn't mind just being like all right
i'm just gonna
just gonna follow the guidelines and
make my way through it
i mean that was like literally i was
talking about this a couple podcasts ago
i was like i specifically wanted to not
have to make any decisions
and just wanted to work on vfx and be
told what effects to do
like i spent a week doing that i was
like all right
after you do a week and you're like cool
now i'm going to go write a movie
[Laughter]
jump off a building i mean that's really
a blessing of of corridors like
really getting to shift gears and
sometimes they are shifted unwillingly
but in a way that
has its own magic you know but yeah it's
you're always going to shift gears
and it's not sometimes it's a little
fast and it's a little slow but yeah
usually we try to make it so it's like
you get a chance to truly experience
something and then you get to move on to
a different experience
yeah i wish i could experience more jet
packs well at least you got to
experience it once
i know i know was that last podcast when
you're like i want to write a jet packs
like you did write a jet pack
it'd be really cool to have a job where
i got to fly a jet pack it's like yeah
that would be pretty cool wouldn't it
though
uh but we didn't have a video come out
on sunday no because it was fourth of
july that's the official reason isn't it
well i mean it is as opposed to
the unofficial reason i mean the
unofficial reason was
we didn't have a video ready well truth
be told
truth be told it's been a long-standing
policy that we tend to not drop videos
on large holidays like
that is true because who some people
might be watching youtube videos but
most people aren't most people are out
doing something
but we were trying because we're working
on this james bond video and there's a
lot of effects and it's a kind of a
complicated edit it's been taking
a decent amount of time to put together
and the original plan was that that was
going to go out this last sunday
before we really started you know
realizing that oh sunday's the 4th of
july we
probably shouldn't upload on that day
because everyone's going to be outside
eating hot dogs
and we delayed it but the plan was like
to delay it like one or two days but
then like
we actually we're short i basically
didn't work at all last week
essentially well you were home with your
surgery yeah i
had a surgery that knocked me off i was
kind of supposed to work on that
wednesday thursday but i was still just
like really out of it i opened the
program i was like
i figured you'd probably be taking the
whole week off and then i flew out of
town friday
most people would yeah you know looking
back
i cannot believe i came back to work the
day
after i broke my collarbone yeah i
literally don't
know how or why i really set the bar
high for everyone yeah i really hope i
don't break a bone here
i think it was it was slightly panic
driven because i i
was writing your attack on titans which
was a really good video i think
you probably kind of had that feeling
like this video is gonna be a solid
video
i had that feeling and it that feeling
just got strengthened
after i broke my collarbone and we ended
up adding more
you took the strength from your
collarbone and added it to the film
yeah it was uh i mean yeah that was
i don't know yeah it was it was mostly
panic driven it was like
i gotta finish this video and i don't
want to be in a position where someone
else finishes it for me
so i gotta do it yeah but this time i
was like
james bond vfx and i don't have to do
that this week
now look at us i i did kind of try it on
on that on
on that wednesday i did open up the
program and i i started doing stuff and
i was immediately like i'm gonna go lay
down
i mean there's no way i was gonna get
that deep fake done last week either
oh that deep fake huh yeah well it's
going now that's right yeah
yeah we're doing a sean connery deep
fake okay you said it
there is a cool running game with sean
connery in the video
yeah which i don't want to spoil but
it's pretty funny yeah
hey another news sam and i finished the
local zero scripts oh that's right
you guys did that last week right
because you had the first episode
done a little while back yeah a few
weeks ago
then episodes two and three yeah
finished yeah are they good like
where's the story going i love them how
does it i think it's really fun
how does it end what's the plot the plot
well what can i how see here's the thing
we're entering marketing territory here
where i feel like i need to keep it
enticing
so here's the plot pitch first off the
name might change
so i talked about this a little bit so
we're not committed to it yet the name
might change to level zero from local
zero
because the plot is about this guy named
zero who's a pro gamer he's level 899
he wants to become 900. actually he
wants to become 999 which is the highest
you can get
but there's only he plays this battle
royale game like there's different games
in this world
he plays battle royale there's only five
people allowed
to level 900 or above so for zero to get
in he has to beat somebody else who's
900 or higher so first off he has to get
into a game that they're in this reminds
me of your uh
what was it the the rhythm game he
played back in the day right rock band
yeah yep same with the drums yeah
uh so battle royale games in this world
are like ten thousand player battle
royale games
and it's kind of like a ready player one
vr style thing like everybody's
everybody spends their lives online it's
no one i mean the last part doesn't
sound as great but the first part sounds
pretty dang cool
the uh this is the kind of world it's
like the year 2050 or something like
that uh
it's 115 degrees outside all the time
everybody stays in their rooms
uh the company well there's a global
omni corp you know
similar to amazon you know you order
stuff and they deliver the drones they
also run all the games or whatever
you're in credits and the games you can
use it to buy stuff from
this amazon like corporation so anyways
zero goes in to this battle royale game
and one of the 900 players level 900
players is there
and zero spends everything he has
to try to beat this guy and it's a big
showdown
i won't spoil what happens but along the
way
zero makes some decisions that zero
later regrets
and it causes his account to be wiped
and he gets set to zero
and so he has to start all over from
level zero
and work his way back up to be level 900
going through all the different games in
this world from mine shaft
to center strike
so to uh what is it what's our mario
kart one
i can't remember it maximo cart that's
the one uh so he goes through all these
different games he's gonna work his way
hello hello yeah
um yeah and you know the cool thing is
so it's
it's gonna be similar to the cut scene
which is that video that sam made on the
corridor channel
but the thing is it's all in a game
world so having it look like it's in a
game
set in unreal engine you know it's going
to be an interesting aesthetic
but it fits with what this world's
supposed to be because a lot of these
days when people make
video game based pieces they either film
at live action and they oh you throw
some points and health bars on the
screen but it's live action
you know or it's fully rendered cg like
wreck-it ralph
right but and you know going out there
doing a nerve that's set in the game but
actually filming it in a game engine and
building
a game specifically for filming this you
know series within
it's going to be a really interesting
way to approach this
is have you guys thought about casting
for it yeah
are you looking at like inside quarter
for casting or like getting actors
both so the other thing that's really
exciting about this
is there are a couple things that make
filming movies really hard
one of those things is finding actors
another thing is costumes another thing
is
props and sets writing is hard no matter
what you're doing
yeah much so and like with an animation
animation itself is hard but costumes
are
kind of free in a certain sense you have
to still design it but you don't have to
then make it
uh having extras on screen tends to be
free having as many characters as you
want tends to be not free but a lot
cheaper than real life so like one of
the first things you'll learn if you
start
trying to shoot scripts like television
or writing scripts or television is
they'll be like yo you have way too many
speaking roles you need to cut it down
from eight speaking roles to three
you're like wait how am i gonna tell a
story with only three people talking
it's like you have to figure it out
because we're only going to go out and
cast three actors that are good enough
to talk
yeah versus eight actors that are good
enough to talk and
if you're doing a union shoot it's
really expensive to hire actors that
are talking on screen there's a strict
the moment someone opens their mouth and
says a word they get 600
for that day minimum i could be wrong if
the rules changed but that's my
last experience with it it's hefty
when you do background work and then
they allow you to speak like
they're all in the back like dang it
come here come sign your name
well my favorite story of that is one
that you told me about jim carrey and
dumb and dumber i think
oh yeah when he comes out of the the
7-eleven and he's like so big gulps huh
yep see you later and he walks away yeah
so those are extras and they're not
allowed to speak
and jim carrey knew that and so he goes
and he purposely tries to hit him with a
line to get them to talk not to like
necessarily try to get them paid but
just
knowing they can't say anything and he
wants to play that reaction
so big gulps huh well see you later
yeah uh so you'll notice like in a lot
of cartoons there's
tons of characters like the simpsons
there's a million characters and they're
all distinct characters
you only need ten voice actors who can
they can do a bunch of different voices
you know but you can just draw a new
character you don't have to cast an
entire new human being who has to make
their way physically to your set
to be in that shot for that day just to
say that one line
you know you don't have to worry about
that when you're doing animation so
i'm really excited for with local xero
to be able to
not necessarily be constrained in that
actor sense you know casting somebody to
play
zero who's like a legit actor probably
more voice actor than like actual actors
will be leaning towards um and i think
that's important so they can really
invest themselves in that character and
figure out the nuances of that character
but now we can write a script we have
10 other speaking roles and sam can do
half the voices or
all the voices you know it's not to say
that sam's gonna play everybody else in
this piece but
it's a thing where it just makes it a
lot more accessible and approachable to
telling a story without
getting caught up in the both the
politics and the budget costs
of every time you have a new character
in your story it means finding an
entirely new human being
in real life who you then have to clothe
and feed
and transport and place in a space
and film yeah so well i mean in that
that cutscenes video sam was the voice
actor of
many characters he was yeah and they're
all very distinct
like because the other thing is it's
like okay i want a man who is eight feet
tall and pure muscle to play the
mountain in my game of thrones fan film
it's like great
uh there's like five people out there
who can fit that bill
and one of them can kind of act
oh and and the other one was
yeah and either way none of them live in
your state so good luck
you know it's like that's the other
thing is like getting these unique
funny kind of cool looking characters or
just even
having people that look the part of
their their role it's very
strict yeah it's hard to find that and
somebody who can act at the same time
who's not already
working in the biz and going to cost a
lot of money
yeah so well that's exciting uh we're
shooting
son of a dungeon stuff next week that's
right this is green screen stuff
partly kind of just well i guess it's a
very different workflow from local xero
but
we're doing it all in real time sam's
got this
really really cool system set up right
now and i'm really excited to see how it
goes next week me too
it's gonna be very exciting it's it's
basically you know it's the mandalorian
thing without the led screens it's like
yeah
imagine instead of an led screen it's a
green screen yep but you still get to
see it in camera so you can match so you
can match your lights manually because
the whole point
of the well there's a lot of points you
know
i started writing one last year a whole
like video essay
kind of comparing old style visual
effects to new style visual effects
with like the whole idea of intent and
you know shooting on a green screen
stage
you know you're the cinematographer
doesn't really have any context for what
the scene is going to look like
and that's what makes the mandalorian so
great or that technology is because the
cinematographer the camera operator the
director
everyone has that context to be able to
like
know what the shot's going to look like
because it's all been pre-made now
obviously we lack the led screens here
to get the really cool in-camera look
and the lighting
interaction and all that stuff but what
we do get
that is in my opinion almost more
critical is that
in the moment context of knowing what
the shot's going to look like
with the stuff in the background you can
change it later sure
but being like oh if i move the camera
just a little bit to the left this way
it actually lines up with the
environment in a really cool way and
that you know it's tickling that taste
bud in my mind
just the right way as i'm holding the
camera which if you don't have anything
to show you you don't get
and that's why i think a lot of people
over the last decade or two
have started really kind of hating the
green screen staged aesthetic
it's not that green screen itself is the
problem it's the fact that it's not
being used correctly
and i think this way we're going to
shoot son of a dungeon does
use it correctly i agree
hopefully we'll see sam's still working
on it there might be a lot of technical
issues
uh including the fact that i'm a
barbarian supposed to be
swinging around a big ol axe and i can't
use one arm
yeah you know the thing about the green
screen you know being used incorrectly
in terms of like filmmaking and like
cinematography we tried to talk about
that in vfx artists react we kind of
touched upon it when looking at the end
of the original justice league fight
and we tried to talk about with mulan a
little bit and it's so hard to put into
words but it's something you can
definitely
feel yeah not mulan didn't necessarily
have the green screen like you know
it never made it into the episode yeah
we cut the whole segment because we just
we had
we had a hard time defining it yeah but
just one of those things that you watch
and just like
why is it all just like medium close
shots and like nobody ever
interacts with their environment they
all stand there and it's all just shots
of people emoting
against the blurry background it's like
that's just what green screen shoots to
evolve into because there is no
background to interact with
there's no chair to kick over there's no
table to slap with your hand as you walk
by as you emote there's no corner to
walk around
as you you know talk and walk at the
same time
right yeah yeah man now i'm actually
getting inspired to like finish that
script because i struggled with
writing it last year and we ended up
just moving on i i didn't get to finish
it
but i i think the reason why i struggled
is i wasn't really able to find the
point of it
i couldn't quite figure out the right
way and i feel like i've thought about
it many times since then and i think i
might be ready to try to rewrite that
yeah might be something we did with uh
like my ted talk video where
um you know i wrote i spent a lot of
time writing this thing and then i
recorded it
and then dean actually did all the the
clips
dropping in all the clips to edit it
together yeah i think that worked well
essays are hard man
like they're really hard like i i don't
like uh film nerd
film am i blanking on his name right now
film nerd
no the film film writer nerd writer
jesus film writer nerd
nerd something yeah uh you know he puts
out a new video essay every single week
and a lot of people do there's a lot of
channels that put out video essays all
the time and
i'm just not a good enough writer to be
able to like maintain like
good writing output and then also
throw everything else you need for a
good video essay into the mix yeah
good stuff well that's a nice little
preview of stuff coming up and things
are working on and
also some deep philosophical personal
insights and yeah guys i'm not a pro on
this stuff i'm just
just sharing what i think so i'm down to
hear people's thoughts and discussions
we're just dudes on the couch let's be
nice to each other
yes just dudes on a couch just dudes on
the couch
what is what is the preferred female
version of dude is it still just dude or
is it due debt
i would never want anyone to call me
dudette
[Laughter]
personally i would call jenna dude
all the time and at first she made fun
of it
but then she just like accepted it
because i just dude is my
gender-neutral yeah yeah pronoun for
everyone and anyone i don't know if it's
supposed to be that way but it's like i
will literally call anyone dude
whether it's a baby or a grandfather or
a grandmother
go walk up to your grandma like what's
up dude i would call like my mom on
accident like dude or brother i'd be
like oh my god like bro and she'll be
like
stop that i'm gonna say she was like
dude
no she hated it bro come on dude yeah
i love those two words yeah just
it's weird how dude is a word that has
managed to transcend
like generations it made it through like
it's it's meme phase you know well like
that was a word that my dad in high
school was using with his friends
isn't the hair on an elephant like
melvin's butt dude what yeah i don't
know or is it
or is it a whale penis it's one of the
two
i've heard i know something of a whale
penis or something
huh it's anyway
what i'm saying is that like dude has
literally been used for decades
oh no dude is short for doodle uh has
such as yankee doodle dandy that's where
it comes from that's how long it's been
in use for
hanky doodle dude oh a dork
a dork is a whale penis
[Music]
right okay i think i didn't know that
dork okay
i'm really gonna start taking a few yeah
that was really been disassociated from
the original meaning
well i guess we should play you out
audience we don't have any instruments
so we'll just say thank you for
listening
uh thank you thank you for watching if
you
feel thank you so much thanks for
subscribing to quarterdigital.com
yeah yeah all right if you i i hope you
are but it's cool
that's awesome we really appreciate it
if you do we make this for free for you
to enjoy on youtube because we know that
that's how you like it
it's been a long day so long everybody
bye dorks